un autre convoi d'autobus vient
d'arriver à tag and drogue ils ont roulé
toute la nuit pour traverser en russie
des femmes des enfants épuisés et confus
mais visiblement soulagé des tris
les forces séparatistes qu'ils ont dit
d'évacuer immédiatement parce que
l'ukraine prépare une agression majeur
du tap sauna et on entend les tirs
depuis deux jours la russie leur
première 3 et un peu d'argent dès leur
arrivée mais ce matin c'est le chaos
certains sont dirigés vers des traits
mais on ne sait pas où on va exactement
dit pavel
d'autres passons la nuit ici dans un
gymnase improvisé un camp de réfugiés où
il a dit cela des sols et des sp
jouer à moss la zac
il est donc parti de deux nèthes parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas revivre la guerre
comme en 2014 comme tant d'autres il n'a
pris qu'un sac et quelques vies
j'ai entendu les sirènes quand je
dormais alors avec papa on a pris tous
les documents et on a fui des rousses la
nuit tant qu'ils n'allaient plus à
l'école depuis du jour parce que c'était
trop dangereux à quelques dames à
chenôve à ne
plus risquer nos vies dit cette femme
avec d'autres elle fait la file devant
la sberbank pour récupérer les 10 mille
roubles que la russie leur offre pour la
transition c'est l'équivalent de 165
dollars un petit relâchement
merci merci la russie 17 grand mère mais
tout l'or du monde ne pourrait consoler
valentina qui fond en larmes quand on
lui demande où il son mari
beaucoup de familles si les maris
ont été appelés à la mobilisation
générale donc si une guerre c'est pour
se battre
il ya beaucoup d' accepter ce départ mi
temps
la tristesse et la peur se lit sur leur
visage et elle fait
mouche comme un signe d'hommage au roi
j'ai laissé ma maison mon mari et mon
fils est né aussi
on aura croisé seulement quelques hommes
comme l'a dit
midi est reparti avant l'appel à la
mobilisation
parce qu'il ne veut plus participer à
cette guerre a pris aux ruses ou pas de
la russie pour justifier une invasion de
l'ukraine la souffrance de ces familles
en cavale est réel et pourrait durer
longtemps et si thammarat alter escaut
radio-canada à taganrog